protect your actors I'm Will Smith from
Philadelphia and yes no I don't give
protect your actors that was that was
either Will Smith or bad day
[Music]
now see I'm not even posed to be here
you know but I came up you know I I was
a stripper
you know but not a master master King
car oh yeah Oh
King Kong guys Godzilla Godzilla no it's
a monster it's it's man okay oh hey hurt
something is it holding a white woman
Leonardo DiCaprio you got that beat up
by war baby oh I I just I'm not going
I'm not I'm not doing this with you
right now
yeah some money pocket study you wanna
be too obvious I'm not doing this big
right I did a movie with him wait you
can't I can't get up right hang on
well he's about this tall decorated act
real decorated active see now it's bad
because when you say somebody's made a
history a real decorated actor doesn't
have an accent he he just feisty huh
means but it spicy about this tall and
you don't take no stuff Don Cheadle
white he's white oh he's white oh this
door and don't take Danny DeVito oh go
sign you know what I'm saying
yo it's like yo when you come to my game
you gotta you gotta come free take a
yeah mmm muscles the hawk eyebrow you
smell what I'm cooking
that's right I'm mr. from the bad boys
are to win bad bad boys are actually the
audience is the winner
did they got to experience that Oh back
and forth running deesigns running day
[Music]
[Music]